am i a person a voice or a raccoon
what am i marvel sure has some unique
techniques they used when casting the
eternals and for some of them securing
their roles proved to be quite easy
being mexican a woman and my age it felt
like they were punking me
for the longest time angelina jolie was
one of the biggest stars who had yet to
join a superhero movie previous to
eternals the oscar winner actress had
even turned down another high-profile
superhero role jolie really gravitated
to eternals because of its
character-driven nature funnily enough
initially jolie wasn't even told what
character she would be playing in the
film which led jolie to ponder just how
big or small her role was going to be
jolie's kids had some important
questions for her when she revealed to
them she was joining the franchise i
think the first question was what color
are you
when jolie assured her kids that she'd
still look somewhat like herself on
screen they quickly asked what her
powers would be jolie noted that her
kids were very quick to get a hint of
who her character was despite none of
the characters in eternals being
household names
when marvel initially approached salma
hayek about joining the marvel cinematic
universe she was ready to turn them down
hayek had been a bit frustrated about
never being approached to play a
superhero he didn't come in my 20s he
didn't come in my 30s and come in my 40s
and all of the sudden they show up in my
50s hayek initially assumed that the
studio wanted her to play a grandmother
sort of role thinking that her role was
some kind of extra or an old prostitute
once she learned the director was chloe
zhao hayek had a change of heart and met
with marvel in the comics hayek's
character ajax is traditionally played
as a man but the role was gender swapped
for the big screen hayek claimed that
this decision was a beautiful shocker to
her hayek admits that she was a bit
intimidated at first as despite being
told that she'd have a major role in the
movie she wasn't given a script had to
enter negotiations and sign a contract
and wasn't able to tell anybody about
the exciting new turn in her career
kit harrington made waves as jon snow on
game of thrones and marvel head honcho
kevin feige had been eyeing harrington
for quite some time a year before
harrington was cast as dane whitman
harrington had actually had a general
meeting with phage about potentially
joining the franchise a year passed by
and harrington received a call from the
film's producer nate moore about joining
the eternals as dane whitman who in the
comics goes on to become the superhero
black knight they'd said look it's not a
major part size-wise in this movie but
it's a really interesting character that
could go somewhere cool i did some
reading up on it and then i said yes
just like his days as jon snow on game
of thrones harrington had to be quite
secretive on who exactly he would be
playing in the eternals but of course he
was prepared i think if there was a
school for that then
game of thrones is a pretty good school
to go through leah mchugh is one of the
more unknown names out of the ensemble
cast of eternals that being said miku's
addition to play sprite wasn't her first
experience with the marvel universe when
she was younger the 14 year old actress
had auditioned for roles in several
marvel television shows though this time
it was a bit different while she was
auditioning in the same location as
before she wasn't told if the project
was related to marvel all the
description read for the character was
for a character with dark eyes and dark
hair which led to mchugh telling the
casting team that she was willing to dye
her hair and wear contacts i think my
second round of callbacks i finally got
real sides and i was sort of able to
figure out who sprite was by googling
and i was like oh my gosh this is for an
eternal i could play a superhero the
next call from marvel was the ultimate
dream come true for mchugh when i first
got the call i was like overwhelmed with
emotions
kumail nanjiani is not typically an
actor you'd expect to play a superhero
but given all the funny men boarding
superhero films it shouldn't be too much
of a shocker when marvel had approached
nanjiani about playing a superhero in
the eternals movie nanjiani proved that
he didn't need much swaying to board the
project
yes i literally said yes
right in the room in fact the only
person nanjiani initially told about the
role was his wife when it came down to
working on how he would play kingo he
had a pretty blunt discussion with
director chloe zhao i was like okay so
how do you see kingo she was like he's
you i picked you because i wanted him to
be you nanjiani ended up going through
quite the transformation for the role in
terms of his body despite the director's
wishes to have him keep his regular body
type
lauren ridloff's breakout role in the
hit television series the walking dead
helped get marvel's attention ridloff
didn't exactly have to audition for the
role rather she was tapped by chloe zhao
and producer nate moore the director
asked her about her passions in life to
which she responded reading running and
the arts from there the conversation
shifted to the eternals and finally to
the character of makari who in the
comics is typically portrayed as male
ridloff was previously unfamiliar with
the character but did her research after
that fateful meeting and the next time
she met with the director and producer
they offered her the role
brian tyree henry was quite emotional
when marvel approached him to play
fastos in eternals describing it as an
out of body experience henry said he was
at a loss for words when he was cast and
that the feeling he felt upon learning
the news is a difficult sensation to
explain you just say yes and you cry and
then you can't tell anybody anything so
then you cry some more
kevin feige has said that the true lead
of the film is gemma chan who plays
cersei oddly enough despite being the
main character the actress was one of
the last people cast for the film
producer nate moore revealed that she
wasn't even the first choice for the
role since she had already had a role in
the mcu movie captain marvel as the
blue-skinned minerva after bringing in
chan for a line reading the casting team
realized that she truly was perfect for
the part and that her inclusion wouldn't
be nearly as distracting as minerva and
cersei are two characters that look
completely different from one another
chan claims that she was pleasantly
surprised when she was offered the lead
role i was as surprised as anyone else i
i was not expecting to be back chan was
already close friends with richard
madden prior to being cast in the role
of cersei but the thought of getting to
work with her longtime friend made her
even more excited to join the cast i
obviously jumped at the chance and to
get to work with richard madden and the
rest of the amazing cast it's great
barry kyon had long been a fan of marvel
superheroes and had even made a tweet
back in 2013 hoping to one day become a
superhero on screen it was a dream come
true when he was approached to play drug
in eternals i would say it's a pinch me
moment and i would say i still won't
realize that until it comes out probably
you know it's going to be a nice feeling
then
according to don lee he was the creative
team's first and only choice when it
came down to the character gilgamesh lee
is already a hugely successful actor in
korea starring in blockbusters such as
train to busan the outlaws and the
neighbors after the international
success of train to busan these fames
started to go even beyond korea i
received numerous offers from hollywood
i got a call from the casting director
of eternals who offered me the role of
gilgamesh chloe zhao and nate moore had
in fact already seen many of lee's films
and analyzed his character even before
lee said yes to the role it definitely
seems like that even if lee told marvel
no they would not have taken it as an
answer thankfully lee happily obliged
for his first major role in an american
production
chloe zhao didn't set out to build
another a-list marvel cast for the
eternals and instead intended to look
for actors who could bring themselves to
the roles yet in the end the eternals
cast may just be one of the most
impressive groups of actors in the
entire mcu
what has been your favorite cast in a
marvel movie